even though the show ended in 1974 that
wasn't the last time we saw the Brady
Bunch
on TV you know et was there for that era
that we like to call eighties greatness
this hairdo now which I don't ask me how
I created this at the time but a lot of
punkers have this now you know see so I
mean again ET has been there for all the
reboots reunions a stage show and the TV
movies your attention ladies and
gentlemen it's a great comfort to be
together know she's gonna look after me
and I'm gonna look after and we know
each other very well in 1988 a very
Brady Christmas the grown up Brady kids
came back to spend the holidays with mom
and dad it's always nice to see everyone
again you know I love everybody here the
report that we built up years ago as a
family still exists between us after all
these years and now it's just like we
never left
whenever the Brady's got back together
it was like they never left so I must
admit it's changed it's strange to be
here in this living room the original
house has been totally recreated they
just stand in the set and I can feel all
the memories kind of rushing through
Christopher Knight aka Peter Brady had
actually given up acting for a while
recently I decided to pull out of the
industry this is a nice reprieve from
what I am now doing which is involved in
the computer sales area Andy Davis told
us wherever in the world she went people
knew her as the family's housekeeper
Alice I was recognized in Australia I've
been recognized in Africa I mean that'll
really clear your sinuses and Robert
Reed and Florence Henderson have all
passed on but to us they were family
this show has a life of its own the
Brady family is part of a Americana and
when the Brady celebrated the holidays
we felt like we were right there with
them we kind of think back over the
experiences we've shared it's been quite
wonderful
[Music]